that's banning author of the sacred fire
of Liberty what's your favorite thing
about James Madison lots of favorite
things about Madison I guess maybe most
of all his moral earnestness as well as
his intellect man had cared deeply and
worried about principal things can you
remember when you first ever heard of
him al I suppose that would be way back
in high school or grade school but I got
seriously interested in him when I did
my first book on the jeffersonian
persuasion which was on the thinking of
the first Republican Party Jefferson's
party Madison was essentially co-founder
of that I got interested in him and I
wanted to see if the sort of grand
generalizations that I'd drawn in the
Jeffersonian persuasion would work out
in detail if you tried to apply them to
a particular man what's the timeframe
for this book this book runs from 1780
when Madison is a young man of 29
entered the Confederation Congress
through basically the end of 1792
at which point along with Jefferson he
was in the process of creating an
opposition party and therefore it covers
what you might say are the main events
of the American found the background and
framing of the Constitution the
ratification of the Constitution
Madison central part in framing the Bill
of Rights and and then the the split
within the leadership that had created
the Constitution that led to the first
political parties defines some of these
terms what's a Confederation Congress
well the Confederation Congress or
Continental Congress as it was known
even earlier was the central governing
agency insofar as there was really a
government
see in the years before the Federal
Constitution replaced the old articles
in Confederation which sometimes are
called the first American Constitution
where'd they meet during Madison's
tenure in Philadelphia
later on they moved around to various
places and ended up in New York as a
Constitution was going into effect how
many members did it have it vary under
the Articles of Confederation there was
no set number of delegates that a state
would send every state had one vote and
they could send a delegation of five or
six members or they could send a
delegation of a couple how many states
were 13 and my thought there were 14
what do you mean by that well Vermont
was it effectively ran itself as an
independent state but it was claimed by
New York and to a degree also by New
Hampshire what was this country like in
1780 how many people lives here about I
think two and a half million or there
abouts and of course in 1780 it was
still in the midst of the Revolutionary
War
so there's fighting on them there's
fighting going on in fact these are the
darkest 1780 and early 1781 or the
darkest days of the war for independence
which is important because Madison
happened to enter onto the national
stage at that point him would never
really forget the desperation of those
times these are months when the British
are invading the south they capture
Charleston in South Carolina and with it
America suffers the biggest military
defeat of the war lost an entire army in
Charleston the British then over ran
South Carolina and moved into North
Carolina and ultimately on toward
Virginia what were they fighting for
then what were the Americans fighting
well you know what was the fight over
about in 1780 well by 1788
still a fight over whether America is
going to be independent of Great Britain
or not it's still the war for
independence where is James Madison
living in those days he's 29 years old
from what state from Virginia where well
his home was in the Virginia Piedmont in
Orange County near what now is Orange
Virginia not too far from
Charlottesville which is about at the
heart a Blue Ridge Mountains an hour and
a half from here yeah what kind of a
family was he from his father was Orange
County's leading planter probably the
largest landowner in the county he was
also a justice of the peace a vestrum oh
no the Anglican Church and the head of
the County militia how did he get
elected to go to Confederation Congress
or the Continental Congress all
delegates get chosen to that by their
state legislatures so he was chosen by
the Virginia State Legislature in which
he had served briefly and it also served
on the Council of State which was a an
advisory body to the government how big
was Virginia in relationship to the
other 13 states very big indeed at this
point Virginia still includes not only
West Virginia but also Kentucky and
therefore is just about one-fifth of the
national territory in the United States
where are you from I'm originally from
Kansas City but I have been living in
Kentucky for so long that I have picked
up the accent and feel like a native
Kentuckian
where do you live in Kentucky in
Lexington what do you do I'm a professor
at the University of Kentucky what do
you teach but a variety of American
history courses but principally courses
in the revolution in the early American
Republic where did you get your degrees
from did my undergraduate degree at
what's now the University of Missouri at
Kansas City was a University of Kansas
City or private school when I started
out there and then went on to
Washington University in st. Louis for
my MA and PhD and what was the PhD in it
was in American history Thomas Jefferson
was your first book how did you get
interested in him well not so much
Jefferson himself actually it's called
the Jeffersonian persuasion and it's
really on the political thinking of
Jefferson's party
Jefferson obviously is central to that
and so was Madison there they really are
co-founders Cong creators what if if
James Madison was 29 and 1780 how old
was Thomas Jefferson Jefferson was eight
years old were they friends yeah they
were already friends by that time and
they Madison had served under Jefferson
when Jefferson was governor of Virginia
on the Virginia council estate they had
already become friends and their
friendship would seal into really the
closest personal and political alliance
in all of American history in about 1783
what did they that two of them look like
Sam hell of it yeah they're very
different in point of size Jefferson was
a tall fellow six foot two I think maybe
a little taller that than that maybe as
much as six foot Ford Madison was quite
slight Madison was about five foot six
and very often many comments are made on
the difference in stature between him
and many of the other great Virginian
founders Washington Jefferson Monroe
these guys were all would have been very
good sized men for our day and were
nearly giants for theirs what would they
sound like you think Jefferson and
Madison you know we really we really
don't know the answer to that I don't
know what their accent would have
sounded like for example how did they
meet they met actually Jefferson was in
Congress writing the
declaration of independence actually
when Madison first became a member of
the Virginia legislature in 1776
Jefferson then came back from Congress
in 1777 went back into the Virginia
legislature and it's at that point that
they meet although at that point there
is a there's an enormous distance
between them in a sense that Jefferson
is already a senior very respected
statesmen and all that and Madison is a
young fellow just starting out and they
they get involved closely with one
another basically because they're both
great advocates of religious liberty and
Jefferson I mean Madison is a strong
supporter of Jefferson's program to
extend religious liberty in Virginia did
James Madison have brothers and sisters
yes I forget how many quite a number he
was the eldest child and the eldest son
of that family but he has numerous
brothers and sisters who range from his
age well down really basically doing
grade school aides children who he
tutored when he came home from the
college of the of New Jersey which is
now Princeton why did he go to Princeton
mainly for educational reason this
probably was probably the best place on
the continent to get an education
at that particular moment in the 1760s
when he late 1760s when he went off to
college partly also because it was
considered that the moral and maybe even
the political climate at Princeton was a
better one than would have been the case
in Virginia you say that he studied both
the Bible and Hebrew at Princeton why
would he study Hebrew
it's entirely conceivable that he may
have been giving some thought to
becoming a minister at that point that's
not entirely clear he could conceivably
had said studied it's simply because he
was interested in it and in religion in
a deep kind of way yeah but he might
conceivably have been giving some
thought to becoming a minister you know
they're in the cemetery in Princeton is
John Witherspoon and Aaron Burr senior
and junior why would all those people be
buried there at Kingston and what what
was the relationship between John
Witherspoon and James Madison
Witherspoon was President of Princeton
and therefore a successor to Aaron Burr
senior would the student Witherspoon was
President of Princeton at the time
Madison went there and Madison also
stayed for an extra summer essentially
after he graduated and studied directly
with studied Hebrew the Bible and things
like that with Willis Minh and then
later on Weatherspoon became an
important politician as well as as well
as president of Princeton and they ended
up serving together in the Confederation
Congress and later on where did you get
the name the sacred fire of Liberty that
comes from a phrase in Washington's
first inaugural address which Madison
drafted for it the preservation of the
sacred fire of Liberty and the destiny
of the Republican model of government is
justly considered as deeply what is it
that deeply perhaps as finally staked on
the experiment entrusted to the American
people James Madison wrote the first
inaugural day he drafted it yeah how do
you know that well actually we have
copies of these things in his original
hand and we have correspondence between
him and Joe
Washington that close us into that what
was he's an interesting thing he not
only wrote Washington's inaugural
address he wrote the House of
Representatives reply to that address
he wrote the president's reply to the
House of Representatives reply and then
for good measure he wrote the
president's reply to the Senate's
response to the inaugural address as
well
when did he admit that ah I don't know
that he ever in fact even mentioned that
but we do do we do know it as a
historical fact we have the drafts of
these things how how did you go about
finding out all this what was your what
was your course of research where do you
go when you want to study Madison well
was Madison this is very easy or at
least with Madison in in the period that
that I talk about in the book because we
have a great modern comprehensive
edition of the papers of James Madison
which includes everything that has been
recovered from anywhere that he ever
wrote and many of the things that were
written to it so the heart of the
research for this book can simply be
done by turning to volume one of the
papers of James Madison in proceeding
through the rest of the vibes it's up to
about 20 volumes at this point many many
more to go before they complete the
whole of his life who's worrying about
those volumes where's the center of
Madison study in other words who's
responsible for well the papers of James
Madison are located at the University of
Virginia and the editorship is under a
good Madison scholar his name is JC a
stag but there's no it's like of a lot
of other things in the country these
days there's no particular center of
Madison scholarship because we do have
these these great letterpress editions
Madison can be studied by anybody who
wants to study nearly anywhere that's
got a good library and there are in fact
great Madison scholars scattered all
over the country now you've got a four
hundred and two page book here plus a
hundred I wrote this down one hundred
and three pages of source notes yeah who
are you who you writing for when you
wrote this book well that was one of the
tricks in writing the book probably one
of the reasons it took me so very long
to do it how long
well Madison has been my major project
not that I haven't entirely done
anything else but he has been my major
project since 1978 and a whole lot of
that time is spent in the actual writing
of the book one of the reasons for that
is it does try to reach various
audiences it has 102 pages of footnotes
in very sizable part because it's meant
to be a serious contribution to the
historical and political science
literature on James Madison does offer
somewhat different interpretation but
the body of the book is meant to be I
hope it is accessible to any anyone who
would want to read it it's not easy
going but I would hope that it's written
in such a way that is not impossible or
any intelligent reader any interested
citizen who would want to do it but in
somebody in your position written a
couple of books and teach history where
who's the person that comes along and
says this is a great book and you say
that made my day it made my year it was
all worth it hmm I mean what would truly
this truly it could be any number of
people it could be a student that would
make my day it can be a reviewer in the
inter newspaper and of course it can be
another scholar
I care about all these kinds of
audiences and any one of those people
who would say that it would make my day
as you sit there in composer's book
since 1978 who do you think about that
would say that's just not right
I mean you know what what world out
there do you worry about checking and
balancing you on what you say here well
there's a world of other scholars of the
revolution in the early republic and
even specifically at James Madison he's
a man who about whom much has been
written he's a man about whom there are
certain general understandings I think
not only among the scholars but
spreading outward from the scholars to a
much wider band of citizens and that
kind of thing have particularly games
Madison these are in many cases
understandings of Madison that I don't
particularly agree with give us some
it'll be will there are many examples
but I guess the easiest way to put it
may be is to say that the Madison who is
presented by me in this book is not as
nationalistic a figure he's not as much
a centralizer
as he is in much of the existing
literature and he's much more a
Republican or Democrat with small R's
and Deeks than he's presented as being a
lot of people remember Madison as the
the figure who worried about the tyranny
of the majority and who believed that
the way to overcome that was to create a
large Republic so that there would be so
many factions and interests incorporated
within that Republic that it'd be hard
for majorities to form to find the word
Republic
well the most simple definition of that
word for the men who made the American
Revolution is it is a government that's
based entirely on the people and does
not incorporate any sort of hereditary
privilege or any hereditary branches
that's the basic definition it broadens
outward from there in fact another one
of the other themes of this book
wouldn't be particularly a controversial
one anymore is that the first political
parties really developed because
different American founders have very
different ideas about what Republic
ought to mean you say very different
visions of the American future you say
in the book that James Madison helped
create the first political party which
was the Jeffersonian Republican Party
which is the ultimate ancestor of
today's Democratic Party so it all gets
a little bit confused
if James Madison let's if you don't mind
play the game if he were here today what
party would he belong to that's an
interesting question because another
another thing I'm interested to see
about responses to this book is that I
think the Madison who's presented in
this book is not going to be very easy
to claim by any particular side of a
modern political dispute there are ways
in which the Democratic Party might
legitimately claim him and there are
other ways in which the Republicans
might do so much in the same way that
you could almost imagine if there's a
contest going on in the country today as
to who's going to claim the Jeffersonian
mantle is it the Democrats because they
would like to think of themselves as a
party of the people or is it the
Republicans because they could
legitimately claim that Thomas Jefferson
was no advocate of big government me ask
you a series of
questions what would he think if he were
here today and he saw that women now
have the right to vote and for that
matter be elected president state you
know that would probably be as
surprising as unexpected in some ways to
most of the members of Madison's
generation as it would that that black
people are able to vote maybe in some
ways even more surprising why
well more surprising maybe in some ways
because as a matter of theory at least
people like Madison and Jefferson had no
doubts that black people were entitled
to equal rights with white that's not to
say that that they necessarily devoted
their lives to making that came come
about in theory they had no doubt about
that
in theory on the other hand they had
great doubts that it would have been
possible for women to be full
participants in a political system
because women's nature and women's
sphere in life in their thinking was not
suited to that one so it would be a
surprise to them although that's not to
say that in every way they they would
have been opposed to it James Madison
was married to Dolly Madison for how
many years roughly roughly forty close
to it who was who was Kitty's Loyd Kitty
Floyd is a deservedly forgotten very
young girl who Madison in his in the
early 1780s had a flirtation with
proposed to was evidently accepted and
then when Kitty Floyd went back to New
York while he remained in Congress he
had second thoughts and canceled the
marriage did he have children no Madison
and Dolly never had any
together Dali did have a son by a
previous marriage who Madison raised is
in so far as he could as a father would
but they never had any children together
what would he think of the media today
these are very hard questions to answer
Madison and Jefferson were among the
people one of the things that they did
when they created the Jeffersonian
Republican Party was to encourage in
fact they thought absolutely essential
the circulation of of information among
the public which would come by way of
the newspapers one of the first things
they did when they became intensely
concerned about the directions at
Washington's administration under
Alexander Hamilton's guidance was taking
one of the things that they did first of
all was to encourage Philip Freneau to
come to the nation what was in the
national capital and create a newspaper
for the purpose of informing the people
about what was going on in national
politics carrying controversial essays
on those subjects and that kind of thing
so they play a critical role in the
course of American history and
encouraging the development of a
politically oriented media public
opinion and that kind of thing and
before the 1790s rover that media could
sometimes get pretty scurrilous and that
kind of thing but I suppose part of the
reason that they do that is that they
come very quickly to realize that the
country is so large that there's never
going to be a way for a majority public
opinion to form and express itself if
you don't have channels like newspapers
for there
and other kinds of media for ours they
can spread information if James Madison
in those early days when he was a part
of the constitutional the compel
Continental Congress and then House of
Representatives in the Constitutional
Convention and all if he were to go over
to a shelf and his den and pick off a
couple of books who would have written
them that that formed his basic ideas on
what government should be I think he
read so many different things that it
would be very hard to pick out any one
or two things that that would be true of
and I think on top of that that is
really his his in the country's
experience more than it is or in
combination with what it is that he's
read they really shaped his own ideas
but certainly politically John Locke
would have been important to him David
Hume would have been important to them
in political economy Adam Smith would
have been important to him but about
Montesquieu and the checks and balances
yeah absolutely although interestingly
if you if you look at the Federalist
Papers what you're going to find there
really is that Montesquieu is more often
Madison's Foyle than he is a person that
Madison is specifically following it was
Montesquieu Montesquieu was a writer of
the French enlightenment of the 18th
century who earlier in the 18th century
who was very widely repeated as one of
the best theorists on on government
wrote a book called the spirit of the
laws which everybody read everybody
cited and it's particularly cited for
his ideas about the separation of powers
for his idea about the proper size of a
republic and things like that around the
time of the banking of the Constitution
and the argument over whether it ought
will be ratified or not if Federalist
Papers were what Federalist Papers were
the most important contemporary argument
in favor of the Constitution at the time
when the country was debating whether
the people would ratify it or not they
appeared originally as a series of
newspaper editor newspaper editorials
and Daniel republished as a pamphlet
they're 85 I think in total now you talk
about John Jay and Alexander Hamilton
and Madison writing those Federalist
Papers who wrote what numbers I don't
mean all 85 is ago how many did
Alexander Hamilton write Hamilton Road
little more than half of probably 60% or
there abouts of them Madison wrote
nearly all the rest John Jay ended up
writing only four I guess it is and what
year were they written they're written
in this well they began in the fall of
1787 they and they extend into 1788
which are the months during which the
several states are holding state
conventions to ratify or to disapprove
out of the proposed Constitution with it
85 different days yeah 88 well 85
different essays over a course of a time
even longer than that because they
didn't appear David how long were they
well they vary some in most texts of
most size ma in modern day terms they
run around 10 or 12 pages where was
Alexander Hamilton when he wrote his
version of the Federalist Papers he's in
New York City and New York State is one
of the key theaters of the argument over
the Constitution and indeed Madison is
there also in the months after the
adjournment of the Constitutional
Convention he went back to New York City
to take his seat again in the confessed
duration Congress where was John J NJ is
was also in New York now you discussed
at great length in your book that the
Alexander Hamilton and James Madison in
a different view what government should
be in with the constitutions and say how
would they how could they write the
Federalist Papers and come out with the
same agreement on or did young and not
only that but seem often so much in
agreement on on the Federalist Papers
that there was a hundred years of
argument about a few numbers whose
authorship was in dispute but what
happens there is that Hamilton and
Madison are both entirely convinced that
this new constitution which the
Constitutional Convention has written is
absolutely essential to deal with the
problems of the country they're both
convinced that it will be safe for the
country that it will not fundamentally
destroy its revolutionary principles or
something of that kind
so they're both entirely dedicated to it
they share many agreements about it but
in the end both of them want a stronger
central government for not just
different but partially conflicting
reasons and it's once that central
government goes into effect and
Alexander Hamilton in effect begins
shaping its course in the direction that
he thinks it's necessary for the country
to go then
Madison essentially originates an
opposition to him was Thomas Jefferson
very quickly joins in if Thomas
Jefferson at Alexander Hamilton and
James Madison were here today what
parties would they belong to I know I
kind of asked the same question about
James Madison earlier but what do you
think
and what wing of the party would they be
and when they liked the party I I have
to think that really the truth is that
none of them would feel comfortable
was was either part yeah but if they had
to pick one
my honest answer to that is that for
Madison at least I am Not sure
Jefferson probably would pick the
Democratic Party although if he picked
the Democratic Party he would be
literally picking one half of his mind
as opposed to another half of his mind
but with Alexander Hamilton did Hamilton
I think fairly surely would be a
republic although even with Hamilton yet
you have a situation where there has
never been in American history a firmer
advocate of a vigorous effective central
government and Alexander Hamilton wants
so that although he was perhaps clearly
conservative in many ways at the same
time he was a an advocate of vigorous
energetic government what was a degree
that might make him pretty uncomfortable
with efforts to to downsize and defuse
governmental power what was what do you
think James Madison would think of the
United States Senate being directly
elected by the people in the state
because in those days of what well yeah
I think not only Madison but many others
of the founders would say that that goes
a great way toward defeating the very
purpose of having two different houses
of legislature well you had two houses
of legislature if they're both going to
be elected by the people what do you
think they would think of the Supreme
Court as it's now constituted not not
the people but as they the impact it has
on the society well unquestionably with
Jefferson and Madison particularly
Hamilton would be a different matter but
with Jefferson and Madison they would
have thought that the court is
exercising a set of powers that they
never meant for courts to exercise that
too many times what the country is doing
is passing decisions that are too tough
for politicians to make
along to the courts instead in letting
the judiciary decide them and that in
the view of Jefferson and Madison was
certainly not what a Republican
political system was all about go back
to the statement you make several times
in the book that James Madison is known
as the father of the Constitution or the
author of the Constitution on what basis
do you make that statement or did it
either make that statement mechanistic
yeah he was common well he was simply
the most important of the fifty five men
who had a hand in the actual writing of
the Constitution he's one essentially
who prepared the original the original
ideas the outline if you will that the
Constitutional Convention started with
and then worked on throughout the summer
to tailor into the document that was
finally approved and he played the
leading role throughout that process you
say that they met in Philadelphia from
10:00 in the morning until 3:00 in the
afternoon six days a week from May to
September and then he would go back to
his room at night and write the notes
and almost quote killed himself
unquote yeah it's it's an unimaginable
effort that that he was making really
he'd not only made elaborate
preparations but because in the course
of making those preparations he'd looked
into the histories of the Confederacy's
of ancient days and modern Confederacy's
and that kind of thing and he wished he
could find out more about those than
could be found out when then this chance
to create a new government came along he
thought we his posterity would be
interested in having better records and
he had himself so he not only took it on
himself to play a vigorous role in the
Proceedings of the Constitutional
Convention but even while doing that he
took shorthand notes of the proceedings
and then when he went back to his ruling
house at night he spent a good part of
this time
fighting those shorthand notes out into
longing when were they finally made
public they're not made public not
published until after Madison's death
how many years you remember I don't
remember exactly they're published at
the end of the 1830s or early in the
1840s
so it's essentially 50 years after the
convention actually means before
Madison's a record of the debates comes
out and that still of course is our
fullest record of what happened in the
Constitutional Convention what are the
Bill of Rights the Bill of Rights
Madison has at least as strong a claim
to being the author of actually a
stronger claim he always denied he was
the author of the Constitution this is a
work of many heads and many of which
maybe his was the most important
although he wouldn't have said that the
Bill of Rights so it's clear simply
would not had there would have been no
federal bill of rights at least in 1789
if James Madison hadn't undertook to
draft the amendments to sponsor them and
to push them through Congress over the
opposition of the good many other
congressmen why did they need me what
was the procedure in which the
Constitution was passed before the Bill
of Rights were passed and where that who
promised that ten amendments or I guess
it were twelve to start with well want
to in fact the leading objection to the
Constitution when it came out was that
it did not include a bill of rights why
would you need that well for one thing
most of the states when they were they
had written constitutions earlier had in
fact included Bills of Rights and to
become a standard practice in American
government to write a bill of riser into
court to include elements of a bill of
rights in a constitution any other
country in the world have them none
although in 1789 at the same time that
that Madison is writing in pushing
through Congress what we call the Bill
of Rights the French Revolution was
cranking up and literally in the same
month that Madison introduced what would
become the Bill of Rights in Congress
the French National Assembly writes the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and the
citizen where did the whole idea come
from for the need for a Bill of Rights
but what was the point well it comes out
of an idea that which goes way back in
American and English history and
ultimately even much further than that
comes out of an idea that people as
individuals enter into a political
society into political organization for
specific and limited reasons and that
when they do that
there are unalienable rights they were
called that is rights which cannot be
alienated by a person that they do not
give up there there is an area into
which government ought never to intrude
any idea was that that one could at
least partially define that area by
spelling it out in a Bill of Rights what
year were the Bill of Rights passed the
Bill of Rights was framed in the
Congress of the United States by Madison
sponsorship in 1789 the first year that
the that our current federal government
was in effect and then it was well ten
at ten of the twelve amendments that he
sent out were ratified by the requisite
number of states by 1791 James Madison
had how many different jobs I noticed
she say you ran for the Senate lost well
actually people ran him for the Senate
one of the reasons he lost that there
are many reasons but probably one of the
reasons you might say he lost is it
wouldn't do anything to to run for the
Senate senators by the way in those days
were chosen by state legislatures and
not by the people and the Virginia State
Legislature was controlled by Patrick
Henry who had been Madison's opponent in
the ratification contest he did well he
was not elected although you can't
really even say he ran is that the first
tenet that would have been the first
Senate when did he get elected to the
house he was elected to the house when
he was not elected to the Senate seeing
you what other jobs did he have in his
lifetime enormous number of jobs are you
know we're talking about 40 years a very
active public service which starts when
he's a member of the Virginia
legislature then he becomes a member of
the Continental or Confederation
Congress goes back to the Virginia
legislature for a while member of the
Constitutional Convention member of the
Virginia ratifying convention then he
goes to Congress he's a representative
for a number of years he goes back to
the Virginia legislature for a couple of
years then becomes Secretary of State
under Jefferson and ultimately of course
President himself fourth president look
two terms two terms what did you think
of him as president or his presidency
easily considered that this is not his
greatest moment Madison certainly made
his greatest contributions in the years
surrounding the creation of the
Constitution a lot of people consider
him very nearly a failure as a president
or not really a failure but as a very
mediocre president at best after all we
got into the war of 1812 under his watch
is not a war that we did very great at
although you know contemporaries at the
end of that war had a very different
feeling than that they thought Madison
had canned
to himself very well you say that some
of your ideas for this book came out of
an interchange that you had at
conferences sponsored by Liberty fund of
Indianapolis hmm what is that
that's an interesting organization there
was an industrialist his name was Pierre
Goodrich not related to the tire family
but he was in Indianapolis industrialist
who literally left most of a sizable
fortune to create a foundation whose
sole purpose is to encourage the study
of human liberty and the conditions that
are supposed to support it it's a the
kind of foundation that runs its own
programs and one of the things that it
does is to sponsor conference inter
introduced small interdisciplinary
conferences around the country and
indeed around the world where scholars
sometimes jurists lawyers people like
that are brought together simply for
conversation about the well sometimes
people like Madison or Jefferson or any
subject that has to do with human
liberty and you've been to these I've
been to these I've even directed a
couple of these conferences for this
foundation in Indianapolis I know they
do them all over the country so that
I've done a couple of conferences well
actually on Jefferson Madison and those
kinds of subjects in Lexington this book
was published by the Cornell University
Press how did that happen well my first
book was published and very handsomely
produced by Cornell and I had a clause
in the contract which required me to
give them first look at this one and I
think they've done again a magnificent
job of production on this how many would
you expect to sell in order to make this
success well a lot of scholarly books
don't sell huge numbers I really have no
idea I haven't thought in terms of
numbers of copy it's a success of if
people read it I'm a scholarly point of
view I guess it's a success if it
changes some people's minds about
Madison a bit you say that you started
out to write a biography I didn't what
changed your mind well I started off and
I might say there there is still a need
I think for a whole life biography of
Madison a really moderate length that
would still be very useful and that's
what I set out to do although I figured
I probably would do something with his
political thinking along the way but it
simply turned out that the political
thinking and the political contributions
during this period were such a
complicated and important and
controversial matter that I decided
ultimately that I needed to write this
kind of a book instead you do list in
the back for biographies and you name
them and as a matter of fact I wrote
down next to them the years if they were
written one was 1971 1919 one 1971 and
one that has a series of forty ones or
sixty one we need to get a closer shot
of that if we can I the audience will
see it on the screen what which one of
these biographies if any would you
recommend someone read if they want to
get a general view of James Madison well
I would recommend any one of them one of
the nice things about the good
biographies of Madison is that there are
very different sizes you could start for
example with Jack Rico's very recent
biography of Madison which is quite
short as a good introductory book or you
could read Ralph Ketchum's
James Madison which is a very fine one
volume but very large in one volume
biography I think it's about 800 pages
and you can go all the way up to
somewhat older but even larger biography
by Irving Brandt
which is six volumes did you know any of
these people I I never knew brand I do
know the other Madison biographers in
European how has James Madison done in
this country compared to Thomas
Jefferson in knowledge and importance in
most people's eyes very interesting and
very different in a way during our
generation than would have been the case
before through much of the early 20th
century probably Madison was quite
overshadowed by Jefferson with whom he
worked so closely Jefferson got all the
attention attention Madison tended to
fade into the shadows that's not really
true anymore
and well it may still be true to a
certain degree in the public mind
perhaps but in the scholarly community
and in the books
Madison not only pretty well gets his
just acclaim and recognition now but
there's been probably as much scholarly
interest in Madison over the last 20
years is or has been in Jefferson and
probably a general agreement among
scholars that at least in the area of
political thought
Madison is probably the better of the
two thinkers in the more interesting
Alton the deeper as you know if you go
down the road here to the Madison home
they're just renovating it's a long way
from being completed down in orange and
if you go a little bit farther down the
Charlottesville there's this tremendous
facility the most expensive I think in
the country to go into something like $8
to go in and see the Jefferson home and
gravesite and all that and there's a
center there visitor center and all
why the difference well it still is a
case certain that in the public mind
there's nobody who's quite so closely
associated for all kinds of pretty good
reasons in many ways with American
democracy and nobody who expresses the
spirit of what Americans would like to
think they are in many ways better than
Thomas Jefferson does that's going to
continue to be the case he is a towering
figure we have a monument a memorial I
should say in Washington DC to Jefferson
what one of the three presidents to whom
we have a memorial there's no suitable
memorial for Madison the interrupt
though to ask you though if James
Madison was responsible for the
Constitutional Convention and was
responsible for getting the Bill of
Rights through later on was Presi United
States for two terms and lots of other
things that you give him credit for here
Federalist Papers which you say are
quoted is still today one of the most
important documents in history what's
the difference between Madison and
Jefferson why the great difference of
importance today and in the eyes of a
lot of people well Jefferson was the one
of the two of them who got associated
first by way of being the author of the
Declaration of Independence and then by
way of being the head of the
Jeffersonian party which came to power
and what the Jeffersonian sought was a
sort of People's Revolution in 1800
Jefferson just got associated with
American democracy in a way that that no
one else quite did Jefferson also had a
pen like very few others in all of
American history have ever had is one of
the most gifted Ward Smith's that we
have ever seen those phrases and Ward's
of hits are going to be endlessly quote
because they're they're so very well
done did he write it himself
Jefferson yes but you say that James
Madison wrote all the that first he did
whatever you know you don't find
ordinarily from Madison's there are very
few exceptions Madison is a beautifully
clear life but he's not a beautiful
wordsmith so that if you're looking for
things that you can put up on the wall
if you're looking for the phrases we
hold these truths to be self-evident and
those kinds of things I you don't find
very much of that in Madison's writing
he's not the gifted Penman that that
Jefferson is also Madison was a he's a
deeper figure he's also a somewhat
narrower narrower one his interests are
primarily political in public in that
kind of thing whereas Jefferson is this
sort of Renaissance man this man of
universal genius who has a hand in
everything let me ask you just a couple
quick note but at a time what would
James Madison think sitting passively
watching the world go by about the
Vietnam War and how it related to the
Constitution well they would have
thought to begin with one of the one of
the things that we're bound to think
about literally at this day is
presidential powers in the area of
sending troops abroad
presidential power in foreign policy
Madison and Jefferson would have had
grave doubts about that the degree to
which that has become a presidential
function and not a congressional one
would have been very disturbing to what
would he have thought of Richard Nixon's
resignation from the presidency would he
have said the Constitution works well I
suppose if you know if Nixon had not
resigned it might very well have worked
in a sense and that there was there is
in it the provision for impeachment
yeah I think
I think you would have well if not the
Constitution you would have said
republicanism works there can build up
among the people a demand that would
it's irresistible what would he have
said about Speaker Newt Gingrich that
not all the things that Newt Gingrich is
up to or are really Jeffersonian on
Madisonian idea but whether he thought
about a strong speaker well certainly he
would have in fact all members of the
founding generation really looked to
Congress to set domestic agendas not to
the president it wouldn't necessarily
been had been the speaker but they
looked to congressional leaders to do
this would he have been surprised that
the Electoral College is still alive
No
would not have been surprised by that in
part because the electoral college is
still alive because it was put in place
to begin with partly so that smaller
states would have a somewhat larger role
in selecting a president than would
otherwise be the case what's your next
book well I've agreed to do a collection
of my my essays and I'm probably also
going to do a collection of primary
source materials on the first party
struggle and I may also do I have agreed
also to do a short whole life biography
of Alexander Hamilton here's the book
we're talking about the sacred fire of
Liberty James Madison in the founding of
the Federal Republic by Professor Lance
banning from the University of Kentucky
thank you very much well thank you for
having me